hey this is presh tolwalker
here's a fun little mathematical magic
trick
start with any number
let's just say we have a random number
eight six seven five three oh nine
now reverse the digits of the number
so make the first digit the last digit
the second digit the second to last
digit and so on
so in this case we get 903 5768.
now subtract the smaller number from the
larger number to get the difference
between the two numbers
in this case the difference is three
hundred and sixty thousand four hundred
and fifty nine
and here's the magical fact this
difference will always be divisible by
nine
so 360
459 divided by nine is equal to forty
thousand fifty one there's no remainder
now here's an even more amazing fact
instead of just reversing the digits you
can take any permutation of the digits
let's just say you rearrange the digits
in any random order that you want
take a look at the difference between
the two numbers this will be 509 4612
and once again this difference is evenly
divisible by 9. wow
so let's just State this formally
if you have a number n and you take any
permutation Sigma of the digits of n
the difference n minus Sigma n if you
divide that by 9 it'll always be an
integer
now if Sigma n is larger than n this
might be a negative integer
but you could then reverse the order so
you could take Sigma n minus n divide
that by 9 that'll be an integer but in
any case the difference between a number
and any rearrangement of its digits will
always be divisible by 9.
I think Zhang for the suggestion
so to see why this is true we're going
to prove this using number Theory but
first let's take a step back
you may remember the role of
divisibility by nine a number is
divisible by nine if and only if the sum
of its digits is
here's why this is true
one is equal to one plus zero ten is
equal to one plus nine one hundred is
equal to 1 plus 99 and the pattern
continues or any power of 10 is always
one more than a number that has only
nines and of course a number that has
only nines is equal to nine times a
number that has only ones
now all of these numbers are multiples
of nine
so 10 to the K is always one more than a
multiple of nine
we can write this mathematically that 10
to the K is equal to one modulo nine
this exactly means that any power of 10
is one more than a multiple of nine
now just like a regular equation we can
multiply on both sides so if we multiply
by X on both sides we get X multiplied
by 10 to the power of K is equal to X
modulo nine
so let's see what we can do with this
equation
let's say we have a number n with K
digits and here's its representation
if we write it in expanded form we have
each digit multiplied by its Associated
power of 10.
so let's take this modulo 9.
so here 10 to the power of K minus 1
will work out to be 1 and then we
multiply it by its digit so we just end
up with the digit this is true for every
single one of the digits
so in the end we get that N modulo 9 is
exactly equal to the sum of the digits
modulo 9.
so let's focus on that
so n is equal to the sum of its digits
modulo 9
. so we want to know if a number is
divisible by 9 that means if it's equal
to 0 mod 9 and that's true if and only
if the sum of the digits is equal to 0
mod 9. so this equation translated into
plain English says the number is
divisible by 9 if and only if the sum of
its digits is divisible by 9.
so where does this fact get us for the
magic trick
so we take any number n and let's look
at the sum of its digits let's write
that as a function s of n
now we know that s of n is equal to n
modulo 9.
now if we take any permutation Sigma n
what's true about the sum of the digits
of Sigma n well the permutation will
have exactly the same digits so the sum
of the digits of the permutation of n is
exactly the same as the sum of the
digits in N rearranging the digits leads
to the same sum
so now if we take the difference n minus
Sigma N modulo 9
this is equal to s n minus SN modulo 9
and that's equal to 0 modulo 9 and
that's exactly what we wanted to prove n
minus Sigma n is equal to 0 mod 9 which
means it's always divisible by 9.
amazing
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
thank you